I cannot believe this but we are less
than two weeks away from the first
official test they say of the 2024
primary season the Iowa caucuses well
this could be the first step to kind of
narrowing down the GOP field the real
cair politics average shows Trump
leading at 51% in Iowa DeSantis trails
at nearly 19% Haley in a distant third
she's at 16% and joining me now is
Florida governor and 2024 candidate Ron
DeSantis who's been all over Iowa
um Governor I know you've been um you're
hovering around that percent Iowa now
for some time and Trump continues to
dominate do you think
Iowa for you is it your deciding
factor no this is a race to get the
majority of the delegates um you know
we've done Iowa the way people who have
done well in Iowa have done which is be
on the ground create the organization uh
the polling is never predicted how the
results come out because it's a caucus
and it's just a different beast and so
we're doing what it takes uh to win I've
been to all 99 counties and we're going
to be able to do a lot more uh but it's
an important part of the process that
you actually come and take questions
from people answer their questions even
participate in debates and so we're
going to be participating in a debate
and CNN the former president has
declined that but Governor Haley is
going to do it so it's going to be a a
one-on-one debate between me and Nikki
Haley so I'm looking forward to doing
that and that'll help the voters be able
to make their best decision going
forward uh Governor I have a question
and who knows how any of us would
proceed if this facts were the same but
if you were leading by that same amount
would you you know you know jump over
people to do debates with people who are
kind of trailing by a lot I mean it's a
hard it's I think it's actually kind of
an interesting
question yes I would debate because
that's what you do uh this is about the
people it's not about you and look he's
got a situation where he gets um a lot
of air cover from cable networks
including this one I get that and so
from a strategic perspective but the
question is is that the right thing to
do no the right thing to go is to stand
and talk about your record uh why
shouldn't he have to answer questions I
mean he's running on things like
deporting illegals and building a wall
but he did that in 16 and didn't get it
done so I think he owes answers to those
questions um he has not been willing to
do that obviously if you go by polling
it hasn't hurt but I think now that
we're in the new year I think voters uh
do expect you to answer those questions
I think Iowans expect you to show up and
debate I think it's going to be the same
when we go into New Hampshire I've
already committed to a couple of those
debates and so um uh uh we'll see what
happens but I can tell you on the ground
here uh we uh we like where the momentum
that we have and uh we're looking
forward to it Governor I want to get
your response to something that V
ramaswami who's trailing by quite a bit
uh said about Trump's removal um from
the primary ballot in Main and of course
in Colorado watch if every Republican
removes themselves that nullifies Maine
and it nullifies Colorado if they remove
a candidate unconstitutionally from that
ballot now I believe in standing on
principle over politics if they remove
Trump's name my name's off too and I
call on Ronda sanis and Nikki Haley and
Chris Christie to do the same thing
their words are cheap action speaks
louder than words now they unwillingness
to do that I think reveals that they're
actually complicit in part in what's
happening even if indirectly
your reaction to those comments Governor
complicit in the law fair against Donald
Trump just absurd I mean I have a
responsibility to accumulate delegates
I'm not going to unilaterally seed any
I'm going to win as many as I can uh and
I've been very clear about both of those
sup those decisions in those States um
it's not consistent with the
Constitution I do expect them to get uh
reversed uh I've raised the question
about Biden I mean if he has green lit 8
million illegals invading this country
um is he eligible to be on so we can
play this game all along I think it's
not going to end up well for our country
um but I do know this that if any of the
other ones of us had gotten kicked off
the ballot Trump would be spiking the
football let's just be clear uh that
that is just the fact of the matter
that's probably accurate I think that's
a fair that's a fair point all right
there is a new ad that we're not going
to play it's so stupid but I have to
make you have you respond to it Nikki
Haley's super pack has an ad out that
claims that you're phony too lame to
lead and too weak to win and that you're
pro-china so you're pro-china and all
those other things given kind of what we
know about Nikki Haley's position on
globalization and so forth which is a
position of a lot of mainstream kind of
establishment
Republicans Laura I Bann China from
buying land in the State of Florida I
kick China out of our universities these
confucious institutes and we've cracked
on on them taking their our trade secret
no governor in the country has done more
to stand up to this Chinese Communist
Party Nikki Haley on the other hand when
she was governor she was the number one
governor in America of bringing the
Chinese Communist Party into her State
they gave land near a military base for
a Chinese company she went to a Chinese
company right in front of the Chinese
flag and said that she works for them
and of course she said China is a friend
now she's trying to act tough because
she knows how toxic those positions are
with Republican primary voters but
here's the thing uh her donors these
liberal donors in California and on Wall
Street they make money in China she
would not stand up to China um and so I
think the Haley as Governor that would
be the Haley you would get so it's a
clear contrast she's grasping its straws
to try to do uh the nonsense and I think
what they're trying to hit me on is
something that happened in Florida
before I was even Governor so you know
if they're hitting you for things that
your predecessor did I must have done a
pretty dog gone good job well it's clear
that the plutocracy wants Biden versus
Haley there's no doubt about that um
Governor we'll see you in the Iowa
caucuses I can't wait to be there thanks
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else